I said all the people you've ever met
who are the smartest people because he's
super smart obviously and he said Far
and Away Far and Away the smartest
people I have ever met Far and Away are
Mike Milken and Bill Clinton like any
sector at all that's that guy's a genius
that guy's a genius please don't say
anything about it he's very old but he's
a genius he's a genius like as in the
Evil Dead Rising as well all right hey
guys terrifying my milk in the guys has
done more for prostate cancer research
than anybody on the planet and he's also
now he's also terrified the kids he
himself is changing health care and he's
like no that's cool
a brilliant man yeah life will hit you
in this dude
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
right now what I realize is that no
matter what goes on in my life because I
keep it so tight and I never take a day
off I'm a good looking older man yeah
you're right yeah no no I said I'm a
good looking older man so what I don't
need from you is to go yeah you're all
right no I don't need that yeah what I
am is I'm a distinguished handsome
cutting profile
I cut through the air that's what I do
when I walk true or false ah maybe a
little dude is so thin you cut through
the air okay did you wear a hoodie right
are you more distinguished she had like
a Blazer on I'd like to start stressing
my abs I should start dressing and
acting my age my mother could have a
hoodie your purple hoodie on your black
jeans and you have beer your beer in
sandals my mother could look like you're
gonna take the SATs right my mom called
me very upset she said there's a video
that says Stephen Crowder's been
humiliating you and put you in a cow
suit and I said Mom and I created that
video he never I know I said he's never
humiliated me we get along very well if
anything it's the opposite and I put
myself in that cow suit and then she
went she goes why and I go I thought it
would be funny I like to push the um and
sometimes you miss so for whoever made
that brilliant video I didn't see it but
apparently you clipped it so it looks
and I sent it to the group chat oh you
did yeah yeah and we all made fun of you
okay well they made somebody made the
video clipped it up you made my mom cry
you son of a [__] good video though
congratulations
I haven't seen that video Yeah somebody
made an amazing video it's just like
Brian Callum is being humiliated yeah
but it but I guess they clipped it in
such a way my poor mother you son of a
[__] hey but you dude you're a genius
son of a [__] my mother's 82 81. hey
you can do what you're told though right
right
it's like Michael Chandler Connor and
and Carter wants me in Cal State and
Connor goes you do what you're told have
you seen that no he goes oh were we
doing this this this and he goes I would
like to do this and kind of looks up and
they're like being pretty cordial and
kind of like saying this you'll do what
you're told and you know oh that's you
right you do what you told right no you
get it here for me yeah then you can get
on plane fly to Dallas you need a
different crowd right yeah you're a
Whipping Boy right why am I twisting my
shirt and looking around
like I'm I'm Zed near the [__] in the in
the basement
you you you can't pair right yeah you're
in Dallas
you knocked on changes
you know what the difference is right
what when I get mad yeah I get mad don't
I no you know what the difference is you
might have a better shot being up
crowded than me right
and probably not a good shot either
because he's a sick kid he's a kid and
he does Jiu Jitsu sure he does yeah yeah
I'd have my hands full yeah well no I'm
not saying you're gonna win I'm saying
go better for you go better for you if I
come no you're still losing the first
round that's super angry and I go I'm
done and I come at you that's where your
anger comes from because you can't no no
you're not winning here right in
Calabasas not one here this is 10A round
you go Dallas this 10-8 here Cowboy ten
seven right ten seven let's be real you
don't get the first round so you're
sitting there so you can hear no you get
up here you're gonna fly to Dallas what
do you do here be honest I'm gonna I'm
gonna grade by the throat shut the [__]
up oh yeah exactly
now look look at this now what happens
here look at this I'm all seriousness
all right right in the [__] notes
shut up right in the notes okay you got
your eyes are all watery Water yeah
right and you oh pants I grabbed this
it's not giant don't forget giant you
can't move okay so I get so that's the
thing about what you realize now is you
push me too far and all of a sudden
you're hugging your own [__] off true
now here's what's gonna happen I didn't
want to do this I'm gonna take scrata go
get the bee suit out no I don't want to
wear a bee suit give me a bumblebee now
I don't want to be a bubbles put behind
the camera do I have to go like this I
like to cry I said put them with costume
do I have to go you know what I'm gonna
do now
fire up the Bumblebee and I go you're a
bumblebee that would have been funnier
though if you're a little bumblebee your
cheeks out
I'll do anything for a laugh that's the
truth yeah dude although I will say at
56 I had a cow suit on and I staged that
whole thing I was like do this whip me
and I was like I'm 56 and I'm doing this
this is not this is not a good look
but sometimes you got to push yourself I
don't know it's funny you're being silly
and then it also gets taken out of
context too so if you just see that like
like they're legit whipping you as a cow
it's like oh you know so no one knows
the kind it was a bit he just bits on
there all the time he's just two bits
yeah
hey also you know 58 or whatever doesn't
matter 50 seconds you think Brian move
like I'm 30 proud or disrespect them no
no
no we get along very little bit along
very well
I uh
I think here's a here's a note to all
you youngins out there ready take
nothing personally keep doing your thing
I hate you know what I hate that quote I
hate things like that as I'm getting
older like I like that people have these
like quotes do they really help like
they're not original either maybe some
yeah it's over I'll tell you what help
me somebody said I I heard mental
toughness described as this learning it
was Elliott Hulse
he's he's a really smart kind of uh this
guy and he said learning what not to
think about like learning how what not
to indulge in is is more important than
learning what to uh think about very
smart guy yeah I was way too wordy for a
quote I'll tell you what's mental
toughness is not stand here not eating
that macadamia nut butter that's mental
toughness yeah with your stupid Hallmark
cards okay you want to stick both your
fingers in there like you do even three
Brandon was like that macadamia nut
butter from how some macadamias like a
grizzly bear just with some honey yeah
it's very hard not to eat these all the
time so my my lady was like I don't
think I want these in the house anymore
because I eat them all the time once you
start too bad for you well they're so
good yeah they're buttery it's a buttery
nut oh I did it uh I didn't that you
recommend that movie that Nazi movie you
know me it's Nazis I'm in I like the
World War II history stuff but then I so
here's the thing I'm gonna get around to
it this week the problem is I watched
the trailer it's too much action
I know you think that but I'm telling
you and I told my guy maybe it's just
the trailer but the trailer I don't
watch John Wick I don't watch Fast and
Furious too much action I think you're
gonna need some substance I think you're
gonna like it do we yes and I think
you're gonna like it because whoever
shot it and made it is brilliant well
the person who made that made John Wick
right uh it's the producers so they know
what they're doing comes after yeah and
the the but the the actors and the
filmmakers finish and the way it's shot
and this actor and like like so
you know in the trailer it's like he's
not Immortal some people just choose to
die oh don't spoil it for me I'm gonna
watch it please don't spoil it I won't
well he's Immortal he can't no no no
that's not that's what she says she says
that you gotta watch what he does to
these Nazis because they [__] with him
the wrong way yeah and I I heard it's
just like him destroying Nazis yeah but
in
but it's more than that gotcha because
you know what because you recommend
movie and you know I love that old
school World War II stuff the Nazi and
SS love meaning I like to study I don't
I don't subscribe to their beliefs but
um so we're going through it and then we
like horror movies and that uh the evil
rise of the dead or Evil Dead Rising the
lady's face on its scariest [__] that
always tells me and then I had a a
rating of like 88 from the audience
which is all I care about I don't care
about the critics the Evil Dead rise
yeah that's very dude and I like scary
movies this one's good man it looks so
good oh you haven't seen it no no it's
good it's not that's not fun do you like
scary movies no my girl was scared I'll
I'll watch them that'll scare me oh I
love them I get chills
this
is when I really dig it's it's
definitely unique where it happens and
they're like they're in their apartment
and they set it so they can't leave so
that's what makes you scared and then I
was like you know I mean I'm always
critical I went stupid they have cell
phones if I can do on 23 but then they
checked that because then they shut down
yeah they they shut down so their cell
phones don't work dude it was it's very
well done it's scary the ending not my
favorite
the worst ending I've ever seen was that
movie with Blake Lively with the great
white shark where the shark runs into
the pillar
she's swimming and then just that last
thing he's like new the shark's like
because that's what you could do with a
great wife yeah yeah and the Great White
runs into the ground and Cat and breaks
his back huh good movie though best
shark movie since Jaws good movie except
for the end which was so ridiculous dude
you Blake Lively in a bikini and great
whites wow take my money oh no no I I
would so if I was on a desert island
with her I was terrified of sharks and
she said please swim to Shore and get
help and I and she and I'd go and she
goes I will marry you I would go
I'm doing it oh I would say oh my God I
would say hold on you want me to jump
off this rock where we know that great
white starch in everybody and swim to
get you safe yeah I'm like
you have to
before I jump in that water
well it's just just so you can we have
to make love yeah because well we're on
the Rock that's awkward it's very
awkward you have to Sharp rock you have
to give daddy a boost right before I
jump in that one I think you need your
strength though you need your aggression
you want to strengthen your wits chance
of me making not good I might as well go
on a good night for me it's like this
hold my breath I go under in a hide
among the coral and I move she tried
that a move and I just slip in because
they can sense things the movie's so
well done I sound like Bill Clinton I
don't know Bill Clinton I don't know why
but I'm not going to get that short I'm
not sure and then I'm gonna swim I'm
gonna get out I'm gonna run I might
sound like Dr Phil right now yeah it's
more Dr No it's more Bill Clinton yeah
I did not have sex with that woman he
was a good president right a very good
president I'll take him over he's
anybody dude think about the balls on
the dude to legit get his dick sucked in
the Oval Office the level of confidence
and ego to go you know what hey
everybody
I'm gonna need 10 minutes in the Oval
Office while I get my wiener or the
desperation I mean Hillary Clinton all
do respect I don't think Satan I don't
think he's attracted to her ever has
been well no when she was young she was
in bad and then all of a sudden I would
bring her up when she was then all of a
sudden she got she possessed apparently
from what I hear
the people that knew her even in college
he was doing his thing and she kind of
made a deal she's very cute there but
you know no back to the day look when
they first met she was like in the
glasses go go down go down she's very
intelligent right there she's so I think
that's sexy like right there with a
brain like hers I would have been in no
why are you still in the murderer right
right they killed him I'm not in but but
she's but right there I to me it's like
you are she's brilliant and young and I
find that attractive right we probably
have arguments they have to make a deal
though to your point they have to make a
deal where Bill's like I gotta do my
thing you know come on now I've got
appetites come on now women are part of
my ammo
yeah I mean from the jump he's been a
ladies man from the job there's a
picture of him young with like long hair
good luck and he's Charming too Charming
is again charmings all get out uh uh a
tall guy actually rather a 6-2
um have you have you watched that um it
was on FX it's on Hulu now but the the
when they did the whole Bill Clinton
um Monica Lewinsky have you seen that no
oh my God it's good my buddy so again
I'm sorry to drop this name because you
know I'm friends with billionaires so my
buddy's actually very good friends with
them because he was on Hillary's
campaign as the I think Vice chairman
ran it and bidens so he's very connected
oh yeah piece of [__]
I'm kidding and he's very very smart
he's kind of like Republican light
Democrat heavy he's kind of in the
middle so he's kind of a Clinton guy
yeah well and and he knows everybody so
these guys were running these circles
yeah buddy David knows everybody
and when I say everybody like everybody
from Elon Musk then who does business
with these people so it's like don't get
into a conversation with them because
he's going to be like are you talking
about the head of Visa you're talking
about my partner who was the CEO of
Apple you know that's a big deal and I
and and I uh he said I said all the
people you've ever met who are the
smartest people because he's super smart
obviously and he said Far and Away Ted
Cruz Far and Away the smartest people I
have ever met Far and Away are Mike
Milken and Bill Clinton oh bill that's
soon Bill Clinton you said Bill Clinton
is so brilliant he said and the guy can
give you an argument from any sector
like any sector at all that's that guy's
a genius that guy's a genius please
don't say anything about him he's he's
very old but he's a genius he's a genius
like as in the Evil Dead Rising as well
has done more for prostate cancer
research than anybody on the planet and
he's also he's also terrified he himself
is changing Health Care and he's like no
that's cool he is going up daddy a
brilliant man yeah life will hit you in
the nuts dude well age is what it is but
the point is that guy's brain if you can
see that brain
sexy yeah that's brain sexy let's take a
little break here A B I'll tell you what
man I'm sick of these sugary drinks and
they mix it with alcohol I wish it was
an alcohol that was just delicious and
better for me dude June shine dude are
you tell me June shine is made with only
real premium ingredients on like most
alcohol you want to do a cocktail you
use June shimes no added sugar how about
that okay what Memorial Day's coming up
okay is it made with the ingredients I
can actually pronounce yes you know I
struggle with that yes okay it's it's
only real premium ingredients and unlike
most alcoholic beverages they are
transparent about every ingredient they
put in their products the canned
cocktails have no added sugar and made
with ingredients you can pronounce like
you said but what if I'm if I'm a
tequila fan what do you have like a
Margaret with four different flavors
spicy mango Pro lime yeah they got all
glad they got passion food vodka soda
they got class classic vodka mule and
that's if I'm a vodka fan if I'm a rum
fan my ties bro why ties all right can I
get a mix pack if I can't just make my
mind up I like everything from tequila
vodka to Rum how about we give you that
all right June shine is sustainably
produced carbon neutral whatever donate
one percent of the sales to
environmental nonprofits their Brewery
is powered by 100 wow energy June shine
can be found in over 10 000 stores
across the country it's available at all
the retailers you're already visiting
for groceries and alcohol like Whole
Foods Target Ralphs Vons Albertsons
Kroger Wegmans never heard of it Safeway
Safeway and more give a special offer
all right at any store you can buy one
June shine package and get the second
for only a penny one penny yes dude
that's basically from 12 to 20 bucks in
value I recommend trying one of their
best selling variety packs that's what
they sent me I love all of them it's a
great way to try all the delicious
flavors go to this go to June Shine
That's
j-u-n-e-shine.com fighter text them a
photo of your receipt and they'll venmo
you immediately it's that easy that's
June shine.com slash fire that's pretty
cool that is cool House of macadamias
guys this is the nuts to eat if you eat
no other nuts the most healthy nut is
macadamia nuts they usually cost a
fortune guess what house of macadamia
has chocolate dip nuts we got them all
over here finally some clean nuts for
your mouth white chocolate dip nuts
they're all so unbelievable one gram of
sugar I think they're keto friendly
paleo friendly collagen production
reducing inflammation they are key parts
of longevity omega-7 fatty acids are
crucial and they've also got the cold
pressed extra virgin macadamia nut oil
they got they got nut Butters that you
can't keep your fingers out oh dude my
fat cat is all up in that butter baby I
love it it's a great snack healthy snack
but also their giveaway right now is so
nice go ahead give them 20 off first of
all the whole order plus plus you get a
free box of worth 35 of macadamia nuts
with namibian sea salt on them from the
namibian bay if you want to know where
that is that's in South Africa Google it
Google it all right house of
macadamias.com
tfak for 20 off the whole order tfak
code I promise you you're the best nuts
on the earth it's the best thing you can
snack on because it's ridiculous you
want to lose weight try these it's
unbelievable we love them that's all we
do shout out to house on macadamias
I can't handle it I eat these every
single day for real
but but it makes sense some of these
guys are just you know as soon Obama's
pretty wicked smart too I I would say
this about Obama
Obama is a great yes Charisma great
speaker now he didn't leave an academic
Legacy he wasn't great at academics he
didn't leave a legislative Legacy he
voted Not absent or neutral and
everything basically he never made a
mark and before that he was a community
organizer so I I will wait for anyone to
show me where Obama was was brilliant or
amazing besides speaking he was a great
speaker we've had he was a great team at
JFK he's a sober thinker he's a sober
man he's very kind of like probably very
boring and but but but as far as like uh
looking at his he's like George W bush
there was nothing about George W bush
that was he didn't academically or
business-wise he didn't do any he left
no Legacy so a lot of these presidents
were fairly mediocre people but right
time right place yep Obama was an
amazing speaker though best we've had
besides JFK yeah I think Clinton said
where I can understand why you're there
and I'm over here he was just his I his
voice everything about him just the way
he came very presidential yes very
presidential
did you uh hope you guys are learning a
lot yes did you uh no we we talked a
little bit with the the Navy SEAL Remy
but with the you didn't watch American
Idol I didn't watch American Idol our
boy jelly roll crushed it I bet
absolutely crushed it I bet and then he
has a documentary coming on who jelly
roll has a billboard in Times Square
right now and the guy is just good for
him and I've it was like Blake Shelton
or someone saw him out we've never seen
a rise this fast that's so cool like
he's just like that's where rise's
Talent will get you Talent is undeniable
the the trailer for the doc is sick
we could play but we just have to cut it
out play and cut out let Brian see it
yep but it'll let you know about jelly I
came out of jail may 30. I was gonna put
every piece of energy I had in the
meeting biggest country music artist
currently right I cannot wait to watch
that who's the best when it where is
that where can I see that it says Hulu
Hulu May 30. that made me emotional uh
how can it not
he's such a good dude you sing on two
albums of ours too yeah the yeah he's
the Future album I think well yeah great
great
um
art saves lives man I'm sorry it just
changes lives especially when you come
from Jelly's past but jelly just had and
you you know this but you've been in
room certain people Connor has this
effect Tom Cruise Will Smith when
they're in the room there's this or
there's this energy that vibrates yeah
and it's hard to even explain it jelly
has that yeah we walked in the room even
before he was big when when he came on
we had him on King this thing in
Nashville he just walked in you're like
jeez it's just like and not a bad thing
you're just like dang it's beautiful
it's just the the vibration the amount
of time he gave it to us like he I did
uh Zanies with him and he just got up we
did a live podcast it was the best me
and Steve Byrne and he's just like he
just gives his time he's he's the
absolute best the absolute best and I
remember and he runs Nashville man I
remember we were out there and it was
after a show I like lost something I was
like hey someone took it and he's like
Brad I'll tell you right now someone
take your watch I forget what it was
he's like I will have it back here in
less than six hours he goes nobody's
gonna take [__] in my city and not have
it back I call a few boys you'll have it
back in about six hours I'm like and
then his wife was like Yeah someone took
his Rolex and literally four hours later
like the guys who stole it came back
great we didn't know this was yours what
yeah yeah yeah oh man she runs things
that's Mafia yeah he's the best my uh my
grandfather had uh some guys broke into
his house when I took all my
grandmother's jewelry
my grandfather Sicilian from Brooklyn
just made a call he made one call
and he goes uh they came into my house
and they took my wife's jewelry
exactly I'll take care of it
that jewelry was back in my
grandmother's house by that afternoon
certain guys like that that that's what
happened they sent out the APB yeah and
they were like get your [__] Second
Story pieces of [__] get that dude I
feel like that's going away because if
cell phones and people can snitch and
lawyers and whatever so that kind of was
hurt again yeah exactly but it you know
on both sides yeah it's hard to press
those people to get it back right and
then it's also harder for them to steal
because the cameras well so do you
notice that but my point was I think
like there are certain parts of the
world where that still goes like in New
York still Boston Nashville sort of but
do you know taxes especially Texas oh
yeah like when I told you I was in
juggling like well that was David Lucas
and he was like oh we got to check in
with this guy so we're safe I'm like
what are you talking about he's like no
dude he'll make sure we're good
everywhere we're going like I don't know
I'm going like Dave and Buster's dude
he's like yeah I'm telling you we check
in we're good it's a different world
check in yeah so so uh
you know Cody Donovan a friend of mine
you met him or me right what so when
comedy work shows hey do you mind if we
bring Brian Tire let me look at my
schedule
yeah I'm not doing anything I'm I'm at
Comedy Works at the end of June so I got
to check in with you yeah oh no I've
already I've already called oh you gave
me the green light yeah yeah you're good
I would have told you what if I spit in
your green light and I just go and I
start doing my [__] is nub gonna be
around
is Aunt nub no my mom got a new hip Mama
shop gonna be around my mom had hip
replacements
we got that going on right
and then we got nubby
once you what's your words here right
yeah I'm going to see Crowder I got
power into Dallas too now all I'm doing
is talking out loud if you say You're
Gonna stack my mind never say something
like that
I would never say something like that
but
when drinks start rolling
and I'm in Denver
and I'm looking at them Rocky Peaks
and yaying around
I'll send you a little video
amen
don't do that with your tongue
hey B
just wanted to say hi
tub your hot tub new hip tits
[Laughter]
dude my when I saw my mom Devin she
couldn't walk oh no I was I was like
what mom had to get so bad the doctor
did the hip replacement since the worst
hit he's ever seen no yeah I didn't you
know I thought she was [__] but that
new hip's a game changer and usually
back in the day it was like I mean
nightmare you're out for months dude she
was out the same day brother-in-law same
thing Jimmy Jimmy the bumpy pickle Burke
uh same thing get hip replacement
because he used to be like major deal
not anymore no no no no that's it in
fact when he when Jimmy got his hip
replacement he was there and he's been
paying for like two years doctor comes
in like this just a guy with a thin
Pencil Thin Mustache not even looking at
him okay he had to wait a long time just
one of those guys and he just goes like
this he goes yep hip replacement
and uh doing this but what you guys
Gotta Have replacement in our heads we
think it's a big deal but I mean but I
but I I can do you know rehab and
something is not nice because but I I
don't want to I just wanted to rehab and
he goes quality of life quality of life
that's all he said because it's not a
big deal anymore I yeah definitely I
don't want to do it yeah but then it's
like it'll be 96 000 if you don't have
insurance so let's get insurance you
don't have insurance things out yeah you
have to figure some things happening he
was like 96 oh no I'm an actor yeah you
gotta have insurance you have insurance
because it's going to run you pretty
good
so there was that
um
oh I just uh interviewed Chell for uh
and he was saying how uh much of a great
time he had you know I felt like an
[__] because Brian after me too
because I brought like eight people no I
loved it yeah I loved it he's the
absolute best I love that guy oh did he
talk about it talk about it yeah that's
how we ended the show he's like I got to
tell I was in Portland things setting
that up he's like he went to the Green
Room yeah he said he talked to his
father-in-law oh yeah his
father-in-law's a stud just a cowboy an
old-time Cowboy Jail's the absolute best
my favorite person to talk to he's just
everything about him he is one of the he
and Conor McGregor people don't give
jail his his do Chael Sonnen was a
superstar who put change the game
changed the game there's some trash
talking the whole thing
the the Kobe comes into Connors whoever
else you want to say that was champ that
was chill I remember him being the first
guy where tell David I'll start talking
about Doug was like this guy says he's
just going bad on the great Anderson
Silva but the way he was doing doing it
and I was like with no gear ah it just
the greatest when he goes well I don't
put people between my legs I'm a
republican so I don't get on my back
just saying [__] like that I'm like this
dude is out it's so funny because you
called me and you were like man Trail
blowing like yeah you used to rob banks
you're like chill I'm like yeah it's
called an American Gangster I mean he
used to rob my admiration grows yeah
yeah he's he's a beast he's a beast
don't let his his beautiful kind
personality fool you he was funny
because I was he was talking about uh he
looks in shape I said I said what did
for you you know I'll be honest Jon
Jones made said I had tits and it really
hurt so I started benching getting eaten
right getting shape not anymore and he's
like flexing John Jones said he had tits
yeah because it really hurt my feelings
I go dude no one submit this fat
shimming works when someone goes man
what happened like wait what it weren't
you're like oh that's the only
motivation you need oh yeah because if I
got really out of shape and you're like
do you look great like don't listen I
mean you look great like I guess I can
keep going like but if I come in you're
like dude what your face you got tits
dude I'd like I'd go to the gym as soon
as that that's all you have to do that's
all it takes oh yeah always works all
you have to do is go do you gain weight
no just that oh no were you up late last
night or yeah well the word the way the
parents do it like man you look you look
tired it's like just tell me I look like
[__] I'm not tired I got eight hours I
look like [__] I'm gonna drop a name
Bradley Cooper he was the same way like
you are like that guy's super
disciplined and uh he had he went off to
do a movie I can't remember and he came
back and he he put on some weight you
know a little bit of weight and I and
all I would do all I did was I go like
this I go how's it how do you get it out
to me all movie like that how does it
moved how to do it even a joke though
like you're joking but even it gets in
there to a guy like that oh my dad
probably like two three years ago he
came out and we were swimming with the
kiddos you know my dad loves to swim and
he's a stud he keeps yeah he's in shape
and we jump in the pool and he I can I
can tell he's I can see he's looking at
how dang it goes
you still work out but no he didn't mean
like to be mean he goes no yeah you
still working out I know what yeah like
not as much he goes that's all
I didn't even carve for two months
that's all it takes just I can see it I
can feel his eyes look here but now he
is
you still work out oh my God what what
are there any gyms like around this area
because you should maybe check it out
yeah like being super nice about it but
I'm a [__] psycho because I forgot to
tell you this so there's a there's this
Jaws or Sizer that thing where you chew
on rubber and it's supposed to change
your face now I saw an old picture of
myself and I had a jaw line bring me up
with Joe Rogan when I'm a young man
right I had a jawline I don't know what
happened but my head turned oval and I
lost my jaw well there I am as a young
man with a nice jaw yeah that's a cut
job we both had a cup we had Jaws on us
how about Rogan says a pic he's jacked
Jack jacked yeah but Rogan right there
was 170 165 not more than that 165 when
he was there that was that was 165 Pound
Road either way tightest [__] rocked out
of his mind but I uh I've been I've been
chewing on I don't have the Jaws aside
but I have a I have a band and I chew on
yeah it's complete waste of time right
because you got the Gill's here now
right that's that's father time I got
kills yeah like yours you get the gills
here the fat girls here
well no my my store mine here look but
don't say I had a fat kills you don't
have it here yours is down here your
grouper fish right I don't have that you
built like Oscar fish take that back
you want to jump my new tank a feet long
you got any photos
exhausting for the hour I have to
Arapahoe or whatever the [__] they are
arowanas I had two marijuanas
I had you that's amazing that's in the
the man cave that's an eight foot long
eight foot long tank because they don't
want us to have to go back and forth
here's the thing B you know when you go
to the pet store and they go hey if
you're gonna get that they grow that
there he is they're getting paid he
grows and he gets along with the other
fish in there right now if he gets he's
gonna eat them that's why I have to get
him out of there because in a month he's
gonna eat them he's too big well I have
a monster fish tank here's a problem so
they don't care they're sociopaths yeah
they don't give a [__] they're Ted
Bundy's the sea yeah of the tanks but uh
and when you're at the pet store and
they go hey you know a lot of people
come in and say they want those fish you
know they grow like an inch too much two
inches every month So eventually you
have to upgrade your tank and people go
ah yeah I'll take it
no dude they grow two inches a month
you're gonna have to upgrade your tank
if they went hey in order to keep this
thing because now I care about that fish
I can't just let him give them away
somebody gotta get upgrade they don't
they should say if you can get this fish
just know in about six months around
this is how much this fish can be to
keep different animal wow legit I mean
because how big is that Arapahoe get uh
uh the arowana uh
the common Fort forefoot well that's
very big yeah yeah that's very big
feeling nice and whatever
mice feed a mice okay yeah
so you need wrong you need more than
eight feet no eight feet eight foot is
the best part because I can set up a uh
a jet three feet long three feet long
specimens that are nearly four feet long
have been recorded but mostly three feet
that's a very big fish yeah but you can
set up so it's like an infinity pool
where it's a jet run the water so they
go into it so it could oh I'm just
chilling really
so they play they swim against yeah yeah
that's one against the current again
okay you know what that thing is to set
up that jet it pushes the water they're
not they're not giving that away yeah
well that's an infinity pool it's a Mini
Infinity that's what I'm saying
people have those infinity pools I've
seen those if that's what you want to do
you get the pesto audition like hey
whoever it is hey man you know if you
buy this thing in six months this is how
much if you give a flying [__] about
fish this is how much it's gonna cost to
maintain this fish they didn't tell me
that to him and he's good luck oh and so
you you got uh you guys I'm attached
you're attached oh yeah
yeah they also don't tell you about the
bearded dragons
you're gonna be buying crickets every
two days and crazy they smell bad each
one noise they smell like you're working
like you're worse because they die
they're half their Half-Life is like
three days and when they die it smells
awful the worst smell you've ever to
open your [__] and if you do if I
took your stupid nose right now and
rammed it in my [__] that's what
crickets smell like yeah okay can you
not don't say stupid nose don't turn
into that aggressive I'm sorry just say
it smells like a game why do they smell
soap most I think it's because they die
like when flies die they don't smell
like that they smell awful
uh-huh
and they and when you buy let's say by
200 you better feed them quick yeah and
the smell of the gases they by gut
bacteria is the stench of crickets if
you put some crickets in a container
with no substrate you can see the fecal
power they're not lying quite quickly
yeah
yeah hey click on it says how do you
keep crickets from smelling
it says don't buy them yeah
no when you start adding some water to
it
trust me this has seven views she's a
cricket
if you can get your relative humidity
between 35 and 45
. I'm
not happening I'm sorry when people use
things like if you can get your relative
humidity I'm like this I'm in the pilot
on the plane's like uh low pressure
we're having a low precious anything
like that I just I just in her videos
well campaign Finance reform uh you know
I'm out there's just give me the basics
I just need the basics
consumer index all right yeah but you
have to you have to take GPT and but
yeah
I'm done any any don't use any kind of
like words so basically you just gotta
deal with the [__] smell of crickets
yeah God it's bad nobody tells that well
so my son had a bearded dragon oh beard
he died his name was beardy what he died
from died of a just of being a [__]
yes didn't feed him he just died of
being a little lizard sometimes they
don't really die like I'm sure that we
didn't they have we didn't know we
didn't have any on the blowback we
didn't have a uh we didn't have we
didn't know how to keep a beardy alive
we didn't have the optimal you didn't
have the question you have the heat
light we had all that but I'm sure that
there are a lot of things water I'm not
an expert on yeah I'm not a fan of
having those things as pets because I
don't want them to suffer and the thing
was always trying to get out of the
aquarium in my opinion means that animal
was unhappy is in hell and someone like
Hitler is probably in embodying that
animal's soul I always think that I'm
always like well if Hitler's embodied in
the soul you want them to suffer I agree
I hate seeing something suffer like that
that just wants to get out that's on you
bro I have three bearded dragons dream
pretty nice think about their lives this
is my argument with people like oh let
them free they should be on the open
cool yeah you know what you know how
they even go live snakes you know all
they want to do is Chill on the Rock and
sunbathe and meet crickets yeah so in my
domain in the tank that's what they get
they have a huge tank all they have to
do is wake up you don't have to worry
about a hot suntan a snake snake no
there's no Predators they get fed well
they're freshwater clean tank they
lettuce every [__] day if you lettuce
all the [__] time see what they get
played with bearded dragons
you're right you're right the worst is
what what you don't realize is the
reason uh like rabbits and squirrels
have a very hard time look at that Birds
go on a snakes dingoes feral cats and
foxes everything wants to kill them and
they're based out of Australia oh just
Australia dangerous stuff they also have
several of internal parasites and mites
so it's not a good time and you know you
know you're that's hilarious oh Hawk the
hawk yeah
yeah so Hawks and Hawks kill you very
nicely no dude they take their razor
sharp beaks through your soft bearded
tummy and right [__] rip you apart
yeah you guys don't have to worry about
that Hawks eats you alive and bearded
dragons they are pretty big too yeah
they're pretty big squirrels have to
deal with Hawks Birds of Prey are the
worst because they grab you I hate them
and they start eating you when you're
still alive I hate them they grab they
grab snakes squirrels rabbits everything
they start eating you and Eagles they'll
kill a fox they'll kill a coyote no hey
Birds they they do it all
so you uh kill a birdie Dragon huh I
should [__] slap you huh through the
easy Santa will take care of it's just
annoying I used to have a snake too
snakes make no sense to me
what are you gonna do with it my son got
bit by the snake thank God
[Music]
when you're a kid oh my son's balls deep
and all that reptiles and everything
my whole childhood was me wanting [__] I
couldn't have because I didn't live in
the United States a dog a snake and
anything else including junk food there
I said it the snake was fine the snake
was for your son or you
it's for me well that's when my
aquariums think Tigers won the normal
sanity I'm like I can afford that as a
kid I'm gonna get an eight foot long
tank
that's what happens too much
I love dogs but dogs need to be walked
oh I enjoy that yeah except for when you
come back and it's late yeah or you fly
home on a red eye and get this dog's
like let's go [__] that's right
I'm going chin you'll be happy I'm going
camping this weekend rent to the RV wow
that's awesome rent a RV I pick it up
tomorrow we're leaving tomorrow you're
going camping yep where
uh yeah I'm not gonna say where but in
the woods we're in the mountains you
bring a you're bringing a gun yep I'd
always bring something just yeah me too
just in case I don't know if Daryl Hill
people that want to come surround me I
want to be or this serial killer yep I
want a shotgun and a pistola yep we got
all that lined up and then you should
wait and go hey boys you picked the
wrong [__] RV
chicka booze might shake shake a boom
chicka chicka boom boom my girl's never
been Cam and she's like oh well like
we'll cook a spaghetti penne pasta what
the [__] are you talking about yeah no
no this isn't I'm catching my own food
yeah yeah I was like yeah we only eat
what we kill
that's right this sounds cool but no we
I bought a bunch of meat and we're
cooking on the fire is it just you and
your lady or the kids too no kids yeah
yeah being the lady that'd be terrible
she doesn't want to do that the only
reason she's the one is for the kids she
don't want to sleep
no I bought a tan I bought it we're
doing it how my dad did with me we
bought a tent sleeping bags me and the
kids will sleep in the tents my lady and
my mother-in-law and father-in-law
asleep in the RV okay that's cool we're
doing real camping style that's cool the
boys will love it yeah
now when I went to the RV I didn't know
I wanted to get like one of those big
buses and I was like I can't believe
they're allow me to drive this thing
this is nuts I tried paying with my
credit card and they're like oh just
show your class A license I'm gonna have
a [__] Class A license like well then
you can't rent it dumbass like that
makes sense
that makes sense because it's a big RV
yeah I mean so your father-in-law gonna
drive it no I so I got the it's called a
C-Class and it has the the front looks
like a big F like 350 and then but it's
the whole back it's it's 40 foot long
the whole back is a big RV yeah
TVs and [__] be cool how far away are
you going how long is it it's like
almost two hours three hours I think
three hours of traffic that's gonna be
great that's like that white one right
there what's up yeah top right love that
that one right there yeah love that
that's almost the exact model my lady
thought it would be funny because I was
talking about living in a van I wanted
just I was I was looking at Vans where
you can have and my lady she booked us
an Airbnb and she goes you're gonna love
it turn here turn here turn here turn
here get to a parking lot
and I and she goes was staying there and
I go in a parking lot a parking lot a
parking lot
I go on an SUV I'm not as a fan it was a
van and there was this little girl there
and she goes just cleaning it and it
smelled like a toilet because people
took shits and there's no questions
there you go I go so we have to [__] in
this van and shower out the back from a
hose I looked at her and go I am do you
know me at all I am an older man yeah
and I am going we're going to go get a
hotel and I'm gonna spend an amazing
amount of money because I'm so angry
but you're the one that hyped her up for
it she probably wasn't even thinking I
did you wanted to live like the guy that
climbs the [__] mountains and uh I
did and she felt really bad
so you guys never stayed in the no man
no I said thank you I looked at her I go
thank you very much we're still going to
pay you but I'm not staying here some
some of those vans are pretty dope the
Sprinter fans you make them really dope
oh yeah really dope but you don't want
to live in it Brian you also travel in
it you dress like a college here you
can't live like that I'll still travel
from here to Calabasas yes that's it I'm
not I'm not going to sleep in it and
take a shower
from a hose because I'll kill myself
yeah those are sick yeah they're sick
you know what else is sicker my house
or a hotel room or a hotel room well
you're the dumb ass that got her hyped
up to do this I admit I'm I am there's
something romantic about it when you're
young you were two gay women who were
Stoners who smelled like Patchouli over
the tracks that's all and so it's all
good it tracks yeah how about the
backlash targets getting
through the next Bud Light why what
happened because in the kid section like
and not like in the back or special
section like in just the normal section
they have underwear for boys that help
you tuck it and like Gabe all this gay
stuff oh that's that's hilarious
consumers removing some LGBT merchandise
following customer backlash yeah
yeah I did I know people say well it's
because people are homophobic no that's
not what it is
we don't buy it we just don't buy what
you're doing
they were selling shirts I'm not a girl
Pride collection over 2000. it's for
like little kids tender fluid mugs queer
all here
calendars and books for children Age Two
to eight titled bye bye binary wow Pride
one two three and I'm not a girl holy
[__] Target learn the hard way yeah I I
I again it's like you're pushing this
transgender chin bring it up bring up on
uh it it might it's on Instagram and
Twitter the lady who broke this she was
like I'm done with Target and she went
through their their aisles and you're
like Jesus Christ take it easy target
yeah it's such horseshit it's like stop
it guys stop it with your dumb corporate
[__] like I don't buy it you're
doing it for money you're also like
you're also pushing this transgender on
children they don't they haven't made
you're confusing children [__] you you
just you just got me going I'm not going
to Target now no
no that's not that Mom's complaining
there's not enough oh there it is Tucker
of course Newsom was like it's a shame
the head of fire get foul that dumb [__]
dum dum Newson he's so dumb you're gonna
need a lot more of them because who else
is going to run for them he's just so
dumb man
look at this the boy section this is the
boy section
wow
is this the board section two
you got to be kidding me you know who
doesn't [__] with his black people wow
no and and Latino people this is the
voice section oh hey we got a boy shirt
hold on
this is the board section
we're in the boys section
trying to make a bunch of little Elton
John's is this you got to be kidding me
is this the boy section two that is for
boys
now if this ain't pushing the agenda
it's pushing it I don't get why they
just don't stay out of it just sell
regular murder I I do better do better
is right [__] Target look at this
[__] you guys you look like your sister
yep
isn't that something she's not even
showing the underwear where they have
special Tucket underwear for the boys so
it doesn't look like you have a penis
this is my [__] mind well go into
Target lose your mind bro do something
storm Target all I can do is talk about
it I'm in a boy I just don't yeah that's
that's real well we shop at Target at
the time and tell my girl like I'm not
sure something else out I'm not shopping
there you're pushing your transgender on
my children they took you down though
okay
yeah leave kids out of your [__]
agenda leave kids out of your political
agenda I don't yeah I I don't know why
they're jumping into it looking at the
back glass because because of these
these so so it started with when you I'm
sorry
oh I'm sorry oh no
think about the five minutes the
feminist movement the third wave
feminist movement the fourth wave
feminist movement said there's zero
difference between men and women even
biologically it was all cultural
Judith Butler why didn't someone just go
cool arm wrestle I'm reading Judith
Butler I'm listening to her interviews I
like to read people that scare me Judith
Butler wrote gender trouble in 1990.
gender trouble is what what is the
foundational text for queer theory that
it was it was talking about this trans
movement a long time ago so anybody
who's uh uh a disciple of this movement
Judith Butler is one is the one of the
godmothers of the movement took a Diet
Coke break as you yeah
too much I'll be right back as soon as
you went okay here we go I'll be right
back think about this think about this
think about this
when they said there's no difference
between men and women biologically it's
all a construct it's all social it's all
sociological and it has nothing and ever
and all of a sudden women are fighting
to be put on the exact same plane and
eradicating the differences and the
differences are beautiful between a man
and a woman anybody who's lived a life
knows that women having these incredible
strengths men have these incredible
strengths and their bartender roles that
are different I'm talking about over
overall the norm are there is there
overlap of course sure but overall there
is a women are tend to be interested in
things that men are not all you need is
have a party and Men break up about
talking about sports and business women
are talking about other stuff that's it
for real like we just talk about
different things why our audience is
mainly men it's just the way it is okay
and when women in the academic world now
the way women in the academic world were
saying know it there is no difference
what you have is now you're saying
gender is a construct now you're saying
and gender is just what you make
and that's when you get the trans
movement the trans movement says you're
a woman if you say you're a woman it's
just not and that's all you have to do
maybe take some estrogen maybe not
you're a woman because you identify as
women so you Brennan could say I'm a
woman with that beard and you'd be a
woman and there are people on the left
who would honor that because they're
[__] not because they're left because
we need people on the left and the right
I I'm I'm I'm honor both sides so we get
to the best ideas far left ideologues
like far right ideologues are [__]
crazy yep
that's not good I'll tell you what if I
was even be a woman though I I went
half-assed at like some of these people
out there do I'm going all in dude I'm
shaving the beard I'm not just gonna
wear it put some work into it dad put in
work yeah you want a crazy diet well no
you already have a nice layer of you
know
softness that would that would no my
skin is soft like a woman yeah but you
also have that yeah but you know if we
were gay you stay home cooked dinner
right
when I get home have hey Hotmail I think
hot meal ready I think you're the kind
of guy hot meal ready I know you want to
say that hold on hot meal ready hey and
don't do my laundry whites and colors
don't put it on one spot what if I eat
[__] it up separate them segregate my
line if I [__] it up
take a hand right what because you only
learn once don't make you do it twice
you're gonna take a hand of me oh yeah I
think I really I think that's the only
time it's okay domestic violence if it's
me and you yeah I feel I'm gonna say
this out loud
I think at the end of the day if you and
I decide to just cash it all in move in
together and stop pretending yeah
I think you are secret hot meal I know
I'm I hear you dude there you go see you
see see you already like you know I'll
do whatever you want yeah there we go
okay but at the end of the day Bubba
I think you're in the ass play oh I'm
lazy and I think and I think you want me
to plow you a new rump hole sure with my
crazy dog and whatever you want to do
but and I think hot meal hey your face
is in the pillow and your butt's up and
after I make your meal I'm getting mine
how's that oh
oh God so shut up hot meal though uh
fine no problem now get on the bed
arse that big stupid Brown Budd of yours
a hot meal though I need my hot meal you
just keep saying that meal yeah it's
fine yeah how was it yeah keep saying
hot meal yeah dinner good
how was dinner
hot meal
get me out of this [__] improv get me
out of this bit
I'm uncomfortable
all right let's take a little break
Brian left to go cook me a hot meal this
episode's brought to you by on it the
one and only on it if you ever want to
try the best nootropic on the plant they
sold over a million bottles you can try
Alpha Brain right now if you don't enjoy
it you get your money back no questions
asked Alpha Brain they have the basic
Alpha Brain which everybody knows about
in Whole Foods it's in Walmart it's all
over but I recommend Alpha Brain Black
Label it's the highly concentrated Alpha
Brain basically it's Alpha Brain turbo
style for your brain but they have Alpha
Brain instant you just take little eight
ounces of water drop that in there and
it tastes fantastic the focus shot which
I love the Alpha Brain pre-workout they
got it all there's no reason not to try
Alpha Brain whether it's the regular the
instant the Black Label the focus shot
the Pre-Workout they got it all and if
you need workout gear you need good
proteins you need creatines you need
fish oil you need vitamins we got you
covered baby for getting swole it's a
thick Boy Summer they have on-demand
workouts home fitness programs Club
maces kettlebells stay at home fitness
we got it all yoga mats sandbags go to
audit.com
slash f-a-t-k you save ten percent off
all the Alpha Brain on-demand workouts
streaming Fitness Fitness Gear protein
powders Warrior bars on it is the place
for their One-Stop shop thick Boy Summer
go to audit.com
f-a-t-k Tim sent off now let's get back
to the program all right oh let me do
chin was looking down chin was like
looking down to go for another Diet Coke
break
the first one
oh
the first team to work out Matt arraza
uh since Putter's released from the
bills it should say since he was
exonerated rape charges yeah I know
Mackenzie salmon she's very pretty okay
well the the message is is part of the
problem right it's part of your problem
that's why we're in this situation right
sorry let's focus on the task at hand
yeah but our boy is with my boy Aaron
Rodgers in New York right now working
out now hopefully they sign them because
just a workout's not good enough we
don't stop there they gotta sign him to
the 53-man roster the Broncos just
released their questions the Broncos
just released their event veteran punter
so the Broncos have an opening
please go to the Broncos uh they never
say they say not face charges after
being accused of involvement in the
alleged you know stuff with the seventh
year old woman they never okay
they never say he they never like they
they can't give it up to say he was
accused wrongly by this Disturbed or
shitty person oh no that with USA Today
what do you expect like
it's unbelievable they never they never
say that she was lying
I also want to say when I was looking up
this to send chin that Google when I
typed in matariza Jets workout USA Today
it USA Today would not pop up I had a
like special look it up you're not
allowed to say that she's a liar because
you'll get sued do you know that
do you understand that so if so so the
reason Trump lost that that thing is
because Trump said she's lying that's
called defamation if somebody is telling
their story and they and you say they're
lying you you cannot you cannot say that
specific person is a liar if you do it's
defamation and you lose that case so
that's why you have to just take it and
keep your mouth shut it's crazy that
they don't say he's been completely
exonerated it's disgusting what else you
got Jen don't get me started
um let's go to oh the Pat McAfee thing
we need to talk about that Tom told us
about this right yeah so Pat McAfee left
uh he was with FanDuel left nice at an
ESPN show signed for whatever 120
million bucks
but he he still broadcasts on his own
and he's part of ESPN's programming but
uh he just says he can't use the effort
as much and the fans he didn't realize
he came out and addressed it he's like I
didn't realize fans were messed up
they're calling a sellout and
he had so much uh backlash because he
because he has to sort of you know he
has to he doesn't limit himself it's
it's Disney it's ESPN so you gotta you
said you never know great 120 million
dollars also he was making he was going
to make 120 million dollars for a
four-year deal or something like that
with uh FanDuel but then this one
obviously has to be more because he
turned that one down yeah so they didn't
release how much money this is no yeah
so it must be a hundred and one million
let me see what Pat said can you play
that
uh he said it's been tough to ensure
that there's an alien inside that guy's
brain
he's great he's great remember what I
told you to do is showing you didn't do
it yeah
it does and I'm like oh no but it was
just something no I was in India
there's certain times where you think
it's gonna go one way and you don't
assume the backlash I've had my issues
with that where it's like oh people
gonna be so happy and they celebrate it
and then the backlight it just takes you
like really yeah you guys are upset
about this you just don't expect
the details you just don't you know but
you know Pat's one of the best so this
is the the what I was reading but I said
a million I meant like 100 million a
year then right yes yeah yes eight
figures per year yes it's more than I
make
what
yeah but no Pat's you know he's one of
the best he's a personality you know
flirts with the WWE too he does WWE he's
a massive person that's great now
remember when Pato is bad on himself
remember he was at Barstool he's part of
the Barstool crew I was like you know
what I'm gonna go on my own bank on
myself and turn down their deal left
Barstool start his own in Indy has a
great Studio there got massive there and
then he's really close with Aaron
Rodgers Aaron Rodgers was his Aaron
Rodgers only do interviews with him so
he became the go-to source for Aaron
Rodgers and he just blew up and he's a
personality great great great at
speaking and articulating football he's
the best love it he does some college
football games play-by-play he's great
or color commenting for it but he's
great I love it he's one of the boys
love it
all right our old co-worker meatball
made it to the shade room
hold on let's see if this video is okay
let me put this into a different browser
so uh Giovanni who's on that show Power
and all that so he only really hangs out
with black guys so he put meatball who
was you know worked for us but uh my
little bro my little brother has never
been to a black game night before look
at Lena's face I don't let me face you
know Christians no meatballs oh yeah
yeah this is awesome his face is so
funny you don't know how to act it's
like Biden at a black church
give it a sec
[Applause]
we got him
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean this is Biden at a black church
five minutes of black church that's
hilarious
oh that's hilarious oh that's so good
I love meatballs
how's he doing man
you're working on Keenan Thompson's
podcast
all right yeah yeah Brothers him
Johnny's crushing it his dad's fantastic
when I play it he's a crazy dude uh
Providence Rhode Island the dad came
through he's the best
it's great the whole family's great
all right this was about I think a last
week we didn't get to cover this current
event but this ABC 7 anchor said his
co-host was a [__] but off air he
thought he was the mic was still hot but
he called her a [__]
and then he got immediately fired right
after that people were getting fired all
the time for hot mics like that uh
report on ESPN called the lady a [__]
too
no we don't have it oh man I wish we had
it but that's the the one he called our
God yeah and they always like they blur
out the letters like we don't know and
then at first they even said it was some
sort of racial thing but it's not a
racial thing no I had to go to the
etymology to look at what you said it he
wasn't on there no no not on air weird
but it got picked up from the hot mic
yeah yeah fire him over that well it's
never you can't there's nowhere to go
sorry I called Mike sorry see you
tomorrow yeah
I mean that's how you feel about me like
he's like you knew this I said out loud
and the mic was on but uh there was the
I think it was in Chicago Chicago like
New York and forget where but they had
beef it's too like big sports radio
shows and then start talking [__]
together back and forth each morning and
the guy goes I'm headed to Chicago I
hope I see your mother so I can [__] her
and even the guy's like
sir he said that one of the co-hosts one
of the main hosts oh he got suspended
they're like well he came back like two
weeks later I was like I am so sorry
he's like this really got out of here
you know they're just Sports [__]
talking like Boston when somebody said
something about you I I was uh yeah I'll
be in Chicago see your mother
when I was like too much there was a
comic who said about me
I was never what worked out but I was
you know at the comedy store and I was I
used to get up on stage and do pretty
well you know some would say yeah get
them laughing pretty hard and uh some
girl goes yeah he called you you wrote
they're killing
and uh like people were laughing so hard
and he just he called you a hack
and they tried to have sex with me and I
was like I was like I was like that's
and I just and he was like hey Brian I
was like oh and would you know that
about him yeah I was like I can't you're
just mean and also I've had to deal with
that stupid and awesome but I know
someone talks [__] about me but I'm not
a hacker it was like just a bad uh the
the term hack the hack refers to is what
exactly like Gallagher would be a happy
gimmicky right like a guitar it's hacky
I mean you know Listen by the way people
with puppets they call it I do fake
right I have on that times ridden a
horse a fake fake horse and and I have
we call that an imaginary cow yeah but I
was making Bill laugh a lot I will admit
that there was a lot of you know what I
was probably hockey the point is I
shouldn't have said that
then we got back dude yeah but that's
the problem when you say that same thing
if you knew it was gonna get back to
that person no not a chance that's like
on Twitter would you say that to that
person's face if you saw them how is it
going to affect them no you know yeah
it's just also just like I always give
people the benefit back even even you
know when I go to certain venues and
clubs and I know the comic who's gonna
be able to talk [__] about me I see them
they're always nice I don't just in my
head I'm like um it hurts my feet I
actually never say that person's not
funny I'm really careful about that I
don't even say that to other Comics like
there are Comics that I'll see that are
you know not my cup of tea but if I have
said that it's really I've heard you say
one person you and I've talked and I'll
talk about certain people that are like
crushed it you'll be like I don't get it
but you never say only to you yeah but
you never say he's not funny or I don't
you just go I don't I would never say
that yeah I would never say but I don't
get it's fine
what's that like it's not for me or I
don't get it like yeah he's crushed it I
don't get it meaning like I don't like
comedy's not for me yeah but I would
never say that publicly no never dis a
comic publicly I I I just no that's
[__] [__] no and I don't say it I I
would say it maybe to you well men don't
do that either men don't get on their
earwaves and talk because I'm gonna talk
to you [__] face to face yeah like if
you cook me a hot man if I get mad at
you after you cook me a hot meal I'll
get right in your face right in your
face don't put your hand watch where you
put your [__] hands right you get
around my face badly otherwise I would
have [__] I would I would jump right
on you yeah
you need to take a break then are you
good [__] come on you pee that hard
can't stop won't stop all right cool I'm
wearing purple um Georgie
this one uh sure this is just a fan
submission fan sent this in to make us
giggle
oh my God
oh dude
okay hey
you know this from being a big guy
they're like dude get on the slide and
he's literally he's like I feel like
it's a bad idea his like worst fears
okay like someone's like what's gonna
you're not gonna break the thing but
it's a [__] Slide the weight limit on
it's like a thousand pounds you'll be
fine man this guy this guy that kill dry
let's all take cheap shots at the guy's
struggling with his weight in a very
humiliating situation I bet he got lit
up go to view replies
on bar stool yeah the slides thank you
um will do this guy needs to reduce the
deal
this guy goes that's exactly you know
that moment scared him for Life yeah
scared him yeah scar them for life
it looks painful
that looks super bad that's a good
wake-up call
well
yeah it's tough damn his buddy's like
doing the worst gonna happen that that
bad right he and he knows that he goes
well it's like your brake why go down it
and I think no dude come on
Step Up the Ladder as it shakes he's
like oh my God he's like man I don't
want to do this and you know as soon as
they're like pool partying like hell
yeah I jumped pool he's like don't ask
me get on that slide his but he's like
do it do it a few drinks like vodka
what's the what's gonna happen it's not
like I'm gonna fall through oh that
watched so this is graphic I'm not gonna
be able to show it on air why but show
it to us though yeah definitely show it
to you guys but this is a 23 year old
dude who went to a bar that pops up
everywhere it's 23 year old dude that
went to a bar and then the bar was too
packed the the urinals so he went
outside this is in Florida so he went
outside to pee he he thinks he fell into
a pond where there was an alligator
alligator took off his arm how did he
fall into it he doesn't he was probably
drunk dude
by the way that happens more than you
think but also I know it's just you know
being in Florida numerous times on tour
any but I don't swim in pools I assume
alligators are Airway
well he must have really had to pee so
they had they blocked out the let me see
so what they do is they hopefully world
star has the actual grab you and roll
and I think the American alligator they
say has the strongest bite of any animal
America
could you put the phone could you put
the phone down and help him oh yeah he's
hammered for sure get out of the water
because alligators still around
above his elbow
oh it took him off at the shoulder
so they're putting a tourniquet on right
now
a cigarette I know that's
a cigarette I love this guy he knows
this guy's awesome that must be his bone
right sticking out right there yes
it means alligator bit rolled and took
down I love this guy how come he is with
a cigarette
no he's not good God bless those people
though you got to tell him that the guy
in the Hat gangster
I love that guy the Hat me too hero hero
so surprisingly not that much blood as I
would think agree and the kid he's like
he was on a news program saying like you
know it was just an arm he literally
just said it's just an arm yeah
well dude he could have been dead dead
dead yeah and that's the alligator they
obviously disposed of the alligator I
don't get it I
also that's too close to a bar and that
thing Waits then what happens is they're
Ambush Predators they go that was tasty
and you know you know what you do though
you don't give license to bars behind
lagoons look at that I agree but that's
like we've been here [__] well you're
the one that wants to drink a drink
we do the comedy zone yeah and okay
right out there is a is a moat right
there uh five years ago a guy exactly
like that what got drunk took a piss
alligator grabbed him took his arm
exactly like that they had to get a
helicopter to land and take them out of
there okay well don't okay you can't
that's a game what you do
is you roll with them you roll with them
you wrap your legs around I remember
being drunk hear me drunk when this
happens usually well that's why Jiu
Jitsu is really important I practice
that yep that's why they call them
Jacare what else you got Jen
um you already mentioned the winner
right of our American Idol uh
demonstrated we mentioned a little bit
you don't follow it so it matter
oh so but did you see the winner from
her name I think I am Sam or whatever
some [__] like Sam or whatever she won
three years ago
um she's basically
performing on the streets now she's
homeless oh that's terrible she got out
of her contract didn't show up for the
recording times just you know
self-sabotage and now she's back you
know on the Subways of New York playing
her music she guy got out of my contract
I could do it myself missed the
deadlines to like perform and wouldn't
show up to the studio so hopefully
people learn from my mistakes he needs
to lose weight because he's going to die
yes and I and I think that's important
too like he's so painfully overweight I
can't look at it and he's gotten bigger
through the season yeah it's it's just
not good it's not good hopefully he does
get healthier I mean I don't know how
bad we talk about gun violence but we
all know that obesity kills way more
people you just read that article yeah
in 2001 I think or 2004 Bill Maher said
what's killing us is not Terrace it's
food yeah yeah but both can be true both
can be true because guns are killing us
and food together it's a nice voice
yeah he's nice but I still know what you
do with him as a star
this was scary so there was but real
quick on the Ian tongue thing so he
people are saying it's rigged because of
his story was like so powerful that he's
gonna win because you know sympathy vote
whatever yeah but that's just some
whatever there's two countries and one
yeah the country music artists is he
crazy good yeah he's good he's
undeniable good and his story I like
your thing you you posted about the
nuggets
Denver Nuggets the the do they do they
win disrespect hell yeah they win easily
they're gonna sweep the Celtics of the
heat right the heat yeah and and Joker
to be the first
player ever to win uh NBA championship
without another All-Star on his team you
know when he was drafted they didn't
even show it on TV they had a Taco Bell
commercial plane yeah
white guy yeah I mean a giant-ish but
what is it really good at uh he's good
at everything best pastor we've ever
seen ever
might be the best pass you've ever seen
is that true yeah and hits from
everywhere and yeah Unstoppable average
is triple double more triple doubles in
the playoffs than anybody
uh so over 10 points 10 points are over
over 10 rebounds over 10 assists he's
good at everything he makes everybody
better and when they gave him the the
trophy for uh Western Conference MVP
dude how do you feel about us I don't I
don't care I just want to win games
because I wish I could break this Trophy
up and give to each one of my teammates
that's what you want
but again I mean he doesn't want that he
doesn't have tattoos and do all this
stupid [__] he's humble so the NBA
doesn't want to give him his flowers
that's fine yeah he's undeniable
uh what team team does he play for the
nuggets the Nuggets no because I went to
a Lakers game I got like great seats and
I saw him and I'm like who the hell is
it I've never heard of him but every
shot he made he would he would just
destroy
that I found I was like that joke was
the best of the chat
Evan Murray best combination Sports
uh so it's genre the guy that was in the
NBA that's been caught with guns like
that now he's facing a big suspension to
make an example of them this is where it
gets scary this one scares me so he
posts this love your ma with a heart and
stories that not that not that I want to
[__] no keep going down you're on it
keep going down they post a picture of
his kid he has a daughter yeah there so
he says love you
and then let me go play the story
actually hold on it's sad dude like
what's going on here the police fast
forwarded here so that's his sister said
love you then post love you Mom love you
Dad
the baby
and then bye bye and they deleted it is
he going into rehab maybe but could you
go and rehab for a gun no the police did
a welfare check and he said he was just
taking a social media break but it is
very cryptic and yeah it's dark
especially what he's going through
that's terrible to think about he's like
23 24. it's horrible hope he's okay but
at the end of the day he's too close to
the flame to realize bro you're still
top 10 NBA player in the world correct
me if I'm wrong Bob like when you have
children and you love something that
much I'm always on edge oh oh my anxiety
anxiety man your anxiety is always
my bossy loves hot dogs loves hot dogs
so I took him up the street for hot dogs
and all I could think about he goes
Daddy I want to say hello no dad has to
sit here because I want my back to the
wall I want to face the exit and the
whole my anxiety and I told my girl I
gotta get at her she goes I thought you
were gonna eat there I'm like oh I think
about someone coming in shooting I'm the
same way above I'm just worried about it
should I read all the headlines
immediately because you love your
children so much yeah and then my
brother I told my brother he's like you
know if I've seen the statistic odds are
mass shooting I'm like that doesn't work
for me but it could be a thousand things
it doesn't work fast shooting it could
be a thousand things it could be it
doesn't work for me someone comes in and
robs it it's like crimes up right now
that's all I think about a lot of things
yeah
uh just one last one but let me put this
in another browser because
this is slow
or we can skip it
oh you're like this piece so tell you
right now he's he's in baseball and he
has basketball he's in basketball too
last night this little kid shows up uh
he has to be somewhere from India's
parents were born there but he's raised
here so he comes in as LeBron sweet
Lebron James jersey on some cool kicks
because the turban on his head I just
seek he's a seek and the mom all have
their heads covered his sisters and the
brothers do and my son doesn't see he's
not being rude he just goes dad that kid
looks weird like that's not where he
comes from that's normal
kid plays
baller
ball best kid on the court [__]
crosshatch
and my son comes back and we're in the
cargo does he look weird now wow my son
goes no it's actually cool dad can I
have one no that's not what we do I go
it's not so weird though is it you're
pretty cool he goes yeah it is quiet
that's cool man dude this kid bawled out
I went up to the mom said my he's
abolishers yes he's obsessed he's
obsessed beautiful I said it's cool
because I I'm sure you guys are used to
it like kids if they don't see it they
don't know I'm like they're like why
some kids like why is he wearing that
hat and then all those questions went
out the window that's sports that went
out the window because when he started
busting your ass yep now that's cool
it's like that's cool I want a turban
yeah that's my son was like yeah
never to cut their hair and they were
there's a lot of things like that but
what the women do it too and they don't
cut down with the men but the women have
their hair they don't know about what
the women do yeah men do
um come see me in Philly I'm gonna see
your boys your boys from the suplex
reached out to me yes I just take some
uh they texted me yesterday and said you
got to come by make sure you go on these
are my guys I'll go by May 26 27 28
that's this Friday Saturday Sunday I'll
see you guys at Helium Philadelphia
comedy
all right kids uh tour wise I'm in La
Jolla first week of June June 2nd
through the 4th that's a Friday Saturday
Sunday one show Sunday that's La Jolla
comedy uh comedy store and then I'm
jumping over the pond you're up uh once
on each City Belfast June 15th Glasgow
June 17th Manchester June 18th London
June 22nd Cardiff June 23rd Dublin June
25th I'm back in the States September
21st to 23rd one of my favorite spots
spoken get you some thickboy.com love
you guys we're out